hi there
welcome to the show still taking place
in this blank void
think of it like the moon in that it's
frigid colorless and occasionally
occupied by one very lonely malnourished
man who's definitely urinated in his
suit
and we're actually going to dive
straight in with our main story this
week which unusually for us
concerns the week that we've just had
it's one of the rare times we're
actually living up to our show's title
unlike what should probably be called
28 minutes on the call tax or whatever
the with john oliver
and the reason we're doing that is that
this has been one hell of a week so
tonight we're going to talk about two
things in particular
the republican national convention and
the horrific events in kenosha wisconsin
where jacob blake
was repeatedly shot in the back by
police and a vigilante killed two people
and we'll talk more about kenosha in a
bit but let's start with the rnc
an event to celebrate the stewardship of
donald trump a tough sell
at the best of times but something that
felt particularly out of step this week
considering we have a pandemic on the
rampage and economic catastrophe
unfolding
and wildfires and hurricanes battering
the country all of which
made it a little jarring that the
republicans opening argument
seemed to essentially be this ladies and
gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
okay then that's kimberly guilfoyle
bringing energy to the rnc that can
really only be described as
sorry i thought doves were going to
shoot out of my hands
and that very much set the tone for the
week the main theme of the convention
seemed to be
telling lies in front of flags because
it was four days of a full-throated
denial
of objective reality for one thing there
was the misleading portrait they painted
of trump's opponents
if biden wins he'll be controlled by the
environmental extremists
we'd be one step closer to
government-run health care
finance pledged to defund the police and
he's even talking about taking the wall
down how about that
honestly that sounds great unfortunately
though biden has promised to do exactly
none of those things biden is a radical
environmentalist
police defunding socialist in the same
way that i am history's greatest
zazu you can say i am all you want to
and honestly i wish i were but the fact
is
it's not even close to being true and
the lies told about biden were just the
beginning here
convention speakers also claimed that
trump never called white supremacists
very fine people which he did
that he passed the veterans choice act
which he didn't and that he's trying to
protect patients with pre-existing
conditions which he very much is not
i'm honestly surprised a speaker didn't
at one point claim that trump invented
parakeets or that he stopped the murder
hornets by sucking them straight out of
the air
and yet even in the midst of a blizzard
of lies some
still manage to stand out like white
house economic advisor larry kudlow
referring to the coronavirus with an odd
choice of verb tense
then came a once in 100 year pandemic
it was awful health and economic impacts
were tragic
hardship and heartbreak were everywhere
but
presidential leadership came swiftly and
effectively
with an extraordinary rescue for health
and safety to successfully fight the
covet virus
what are you doing you can't talk about
the coronavirus in the past
tense when it is in a very real sense
still raging
if you're a character in a saw movie you
don't say that was a close one while the
bear trap is still on your head
but maybe the biggest gulf between the r
c and objective reality concerned race
because again and again rnc speakers
were at pains to reassure viewers that
racism in america
is mostly a relic of the past and
whatever remains can be easily overcome
take nikki haley's speech in which she
flatly insisted america is not a racist
country
and then told the inspirational story of
how the confederate flag at her state's
capital
was taken down in 2015 after the
massacre at mother emanuel church
after that horrific tragedy we didn't
turn against each other
we came together black and white
democrat and republican together we made
the hard choices
needed to heal and removed a divisive
symbol
peacefully and respectfully oh
that's what happened is it that sounds
nice just a few things there
it's a peaceful story of unity and hope
as long as you start that story
immediately after
a white supremacist killed nine people
at a historic black church
also haley's version of that story
ignores the fact that the eventual
removal of the confederate flag was
jump-started by artists and activists
bryn use and bass
climbing the flagpole in front of the
state house like she was on an
anti-racist version of american ninja
warrior and that she was then arrested
and that the flag was then re-raised 45
minutes later
haley also conveniently leaves out the
part where the candidate she's endorsing
has defended those who proudly fly the
flag by saying it represents the south
so haley turning what happened in south
carolina into a smooth
hopeful story of racial reconciliation
it's a bit like if someone asked her
what the film do the right thing is
about and she said a brooklyn
neighborhood
comes together to help redecorate a
pizza place i mean
sure nikki i guess that's technically
true but it feels like you're leaving
out some pretty important parts
there
and a lot of the rnc's messaging on race
seemed intended not so much to win
over black voters as to reassure white
people that they could vote republican
without being racist the audience they
were talking to was pretty clear even in
small moments like this
the american people know we don't have
to choose between supporting law
enforcement
and standing with our african-american
neighbors well
hold on there mike who is the we in that
sentence
because it seems like you're making a
distinction between we the american
people and
our african-american neighbors who i
guess by extension are somehow a
different group entirely
but i guess that sentiment shouldn't
really be surprising coming from mike
pence
a man who permanently looks like he
should be living in ken's white flight
dream house
and all of this overt talk of racial
harmony was very much in conflict with
the steady diet of barely disguised
racial panic
that viewers were also being fed perhaps
the most flagrant example of this
came on monday night when the rnc chose
to feature the saint louis couple who
were charged with threatening black
lives matter protesters
at gunpoint last month and the message
that they were there to send
was pretty clear it seems as if the
democrats no longer view the
government's job
as protecting honest citizens from
criminals
but rather protecting criminals from
honest citizens they're not satisfied
with spreading the chaos and violence
into our communities they want to
abolish the suburbs altogether
by ending single-family home zoning this
forestry zoning would bring crime
lawlessness and low-quality apartments
into now thriving suburban neighborhoods
so make no mistake no matter where you
live
your family will not be safe in the
radical democrats
america wow okay first c-span you really
didn't need to put up the banner that
says they're personal injury attorneys i
very much got that from the
everything but much more importantly
think about how incendiary that message
is
violence and criminals are coming to
your community in the form of low
quality apartments and you must defend
yourself take it from us
the couple who pointed guns at black
lives matter protesters
and rhetoric like that and the world
view it encompasses
has consequences which actually brings
us to the second part of our story this
week
what happened in kenosha wisconsin where
to reiterate
jacob blake was shot seven times in the
back by police
with three of his children in the car
and then in the protest that followed
kyle rittenhouse a 17 year old who
traveled there from out of state
and was illegally carrying a weapon
killed two people and look
i don't know if he saw the mccloskey
speak the night before he chose to
drive to a city he didn't live in to
defend property he didn't own
what i do know is that he was an avid
trump supporter
even sitting front row at a rally back
in january
and trump and his media ecosystem have
been delivering essentially the same
message as the mccloskeys
for years now just look at how quickly
tucker carlson moved to try and explain
away written house's actions
as a natural response so are we really
surprised that looting and
arson accelerated to murder how shocked
are we that 17 year olds with rifles
decided they had to maintain order
when no one else would well you don't
seem to be shocked
and that alone should actually be pretty
shocking because let's be clear
a 17 year old vigilante with a rifle
cannot maintain order
because a 17 year old vigilante with a
rifle trying to maintain order
is himself the definition of disorder
except of course if you're a regular
viewer of tucker carlson a show that
exists to teach its viewers
precisely three things property damage
is violence
homicide is order and pillows are for
sale
and the events in kenosha really hammer
home the
flagrant double standard baked into
american society
just look at the difference in how the
police in kenosha responded to blake
and how they responded to rittenhouse
alleged gunman kyle rittenhouse walking
away
gun in tow as people screamed that he
just shot protesters
one law enforcement officer seeming to
ask rittenhouse if anyone was hurt
two incidents two videos with some
asking why
two different responses why two
different responses
i think the answer to that is pretty
obvious it's the same reason why ahead
of the shooting there was video of the
police trying to enforce a curfew
against protesters even as
they offered water to written house and
the militias saying and i quote
we appreciate you guys we really do and
if you're looking for a better visual
illustration
of the differences between being black
and white in america i don't think
you're going to find one except
maybe forcing exactly who sits down and
who stands up
when cotton eye joe comes on at a
wedding and that disparity in treatment
continued even after the shootings
just watch how the next day the kenosha
police chief
couldn't help but spread blame to the
protesters who were shot at and killed
everybody involved was out after the
curfew i'm not going to make a great
deal of that but the point is
the curfews in place to protect had
persons not been
out involved in in violation of that
perhaps the situation that that unfolded
would not have happened okay first of
all thanks so much
for not making a great deal out of that
the people who got murdered were up
way past their government post bedtime
and you were nice enough not to even
mention it except to
imply that maybe it was a reason they
kinda had it coming and that is the kind
of restraint that we've all now come to
expect
from the kenosha police department and
you might think well hold on
that's just one guy surely not all law
enforcement there thinks that way
although i will point out to you that
the guy standing next to him is the
kenosha sheriff who
just two years ago gave a pretty
striking press conference
a group of five young black people had
allegedly stolen some clothing from an
outlet mall
and had led police on a chase that ended
in a minor car accident and in that
press conference
he expressed some views that are pretty
explicit
let's put them in jail let's let's stop
them
from truly at least some of these males
going out
and getting 10 other women pregnant and
having small children
let's put them away at some point
we have to stop being politically
correct sorry can i quickly uh interrupt
you there because
calling for american citizens to be
stopped from having small children
isn't politically incorrect so much as
politically 1940s germany
and he wasn't just idly saying that he'd
really thought through
a whole plan and i know it is deeply
unpleasant
but honestly it is worth listening to
just how detailed his solution was
if there's a threshold that they cross
these people have to be warehoused no
recreational time
in the jails we put them away and maybe
we got to do is build warehouses that
after this generation is gone
they've perished in these buildings we
can turn them into something else
maybe malls maybe maybe uh
amazon will buy them as warehouses later
but at some point we have to get rid of
this group of people we have to lock
them up i don't think i'm saying
anything different than most people in
society aren't thinking
but they're afraid to say it and i'm
just to the point that i'm i'm saying it
okay if that is what most people in
society are thinking then we are and
this is true
a terrible society and i honestly cannot
believe
that was an idea from a still employed
sheriff and not
a pitch from shark tank lights genocide
edition
good question there mark cuban the
answer is these concentration camps
could easily be converted into amazon
warehouses
looks like i've got a bidding war on my
hands and look
the events in kenosha would be
infuriating at any time but it's somehow
especially infuriating that they took
place
in the same week where the rnc was
desperate to reassure the country that
america isn't racist
while simultaneously fear-mongering
about violent crime threatening
law-abiding citizens it was a disconnect
that was pretty well summed up
by nba coach doc rivers in an emotional
post-game press conference on tuesday
what stands out to me is um
just just watching the republican
revenge our convention
and this they're spewing this fear right
like all you hear donald trump and
all of them talking about fear we're the
ones getting killed
we're the ones getting shot uh we're the
ones that
we're denied to live in certain
communities
um we've been hung we've been shot
and
all you do is keep hearing about fear
it's
it's amazing why we keep
loving this country and this country
does not love us back
yeah exactly it's all exhaustingly
depressing
although in a week of incredible
darkness there was
actually a bright spot because shortly
after doc rivers spoke there
something genuinely extraordinary
started to happen in his sport
the milwaukee bucks had a playoff game
but didn't take the court with rumors
starting to fly around
that they were about to refuse to play
then wnba players who incidentally
have led from the start on the black
lives matter movement also refused to
play
after arriving at a scheduled game with
church with seven bullet holes drawn on
their back
and eventually wildcat strikes spread
throughout both
leagues in an unprecedented and
genuinely inspiring show of collective
action and they did this
without union approval so they were
putting a lot on the line here their
income
and maybe even their careers which is
what makes it so
infuriating that when jared kushner was
asked for his response to the strike
this is what fell out of his mouth look
i think that the nba players
are very fortunate that they have the
financial position where they're able to
take a night off from work without uh
having to
to have the consequences to themselves
financially so they have that luxury
which is great
okay first get jared you welcome
to marwyn reject cause for start
they're not taking a night off from work
the emotional toll of being black in
america
combined with the pressure to perform at
an elite level during a global pandemic
is
i'm guessing pretty taxing so by not
playing
they're not exactly taking a spa day and
if nba players are too rich to take
meaningful action then who exactly is
in the right tax bracket to have their
protest approved by america's most
laminated prince because we have seen
time and time again
that wealth and fame absolutely do not
protect you as a black athlete
it didn't protect sterling brown from
getting tased by the police after being
stopped
for a parking violation in milwaukee and
it didn't protect tarbo cephalosia
from having his leg broken by nypd
officers in an incident that forced him
to miss the 2015 playoffs
and put his whole career in jeopardy and
you might want to strap
in jared because this probably isn't the
last disruptive action like this that
we're going to see going forward
nor should it be because people are sick
of waiting just listen to jacob blake's
sister letitra wideman making that
very clear i'm not sad i'm not sorry
i'm angry and i'm tired
i haven't cried one time i stopped
crying
years ago i am numb
i have been watching police murder
people that look like me
for years i'm not sad i don't want your
pity
i want change right this can't be about
it can't be about sympathy that is why
there is no section in greeting card
stores labeled
centuries of oppression this isn't about
what white people
feel or say this has to be about
creating
real change in a system that has been
built to be non-responsive
because history has repeatedly shown us
the system does not respond
until it is forced to so it's easy for
rnc speakers to insist that the
only appropriate action is peaceful and
unobtrusive but the fact is
that's just not how it works thousands
of people marched in the wake of george
floyd's death
and have continued marching even as
media coverage has steadily drifted away
meanwhile the mba has made a lot of
symbolic gestures of support for the
movement like painting
black lives matter on the court and
allowing players to wear a social
justice message on their jerseys
selected by the way from a list of 29
agreed-upon options
but to underscore just how limiting that
kind of pre-approved protest can be
say her name was on the list but brianna
taylor
was not and i guess the only positive
thing there is that if players wanted to
protest that particular restriction the
nba had a jersey ready made for them
the problem with purely symbolic protest
is that it's far too easy to co-opt
and there might actually be no more
visceral example of that than the fact
that that kenosha sheriff and
human warehousing innovator got positive
attention earlier this year
when he kneeled for nine minutes in
solidarity with the black lives matter
movement
so is it any wonder the basketball
players felt they had to escalate their
protest by
not just wearing a jersey but by
striking and in doing so
putting team owners money at jeopardy
because real discomfort
is the only thing that's going to bring
about real change here
and it's worth noting that already the
strike has had some effect
not only did it spread to other sports
and other athletes
but the nba players now have a promise
from owners to convert as many of their
arenas as possible
into polling places this november which
is great
although it also brings us to the fact
that simply voting this november is
clearly
not going to be nearly enough because as
much as i or the rnc would like to
believe that
joe biden will be an agent of radical
change
there's just no reason to believe that
to the extent that real change is
possible through the ballot box this
year it will only be if biden is elected
alongside progressive candidates
all the way down the ballot from the
senate to state legislatures to city
councils
to sheriffs and even that will be very
much a beginning
and not an end none of this is easy but
it has to begin
and now because our current situation is
completely unacceptable
and the rnc this week actually ended up
being a pretty good reminder
that where we still might end up going
is genuinely terrifying
because if it showed us one thing this
week it's the danger in continuing to be
governed
by an administration that encourages the
ugliest forces in american society
that lionizes threats of violence
against peaceful protest
that tells us there is no conflict
between supporting law enforcement and
our african-american neighbors and that
insists that the best is yet to come
which
given everything that we've seen in the
last four years is sounding less like a
promise
and more like a threat
you